In our neighborhood, I can do all my errands.
Marsha, before we get ice cream, I need to return three books to the library.
Where is the library?
It is on this street on the corner.
Awesome!
Let's go!
Marsha, I can return the books here.
Anna, what are those in the books?
Marsha, these are letters to my family and friends back home.
Four letters! Is there a post office near here?
Um, no. The post office is far from here.
But there is a mailbox across from the store.
Awesome! Let's go!
Marsha, now I need to buy stamps.
Do you have cash?
No. Is there a bank near here?
There is a bank behind you.
Thanks, Marsha. You know our neighborhood so well.
Now I have cash.
I can buy stamps.
That store sells stamps.
Wait here.
I have stamps.
Wow, you're fast.
Do you have more cash?
I do.
Ice cream!